thank Isola from the New York Daily News
SiriusXM NBA radio and one of the stars
of around the horn kind enough to join
us here that's a that's a big business
card you got there look at you I just
had a son graduate college a daughter's
in college I need all the jobs that can
get best job that you have if I said you
could only do one of these around the
horn New York Daily News I'm gonna say
around the honkers it pays the money now
do you get paid per appearance okay do
you get paid any extra if you win no
unfortunately no but everybody yes I
want to be I'm like the lefty reliever
who pitches the sixth and seventh inning
I just want the appearances it's not
based on the winds and you could win
your 20 games let me just have the most
appearances on the year now Calais Sean
got in trouble because he said he tanked
a show to get out early one day yeah
yeah I wouldn't I would tank because I
didn't have anything good to say at the
end of the show when you have your face
okay but there have been times when I
really wanted to win and I thought I've
had a good face time and then Tony if
you look I think because I'm in the
studio in New York and Tony thinks that
you know he and I are too much alike for
whatever reason even though he's a lot
younger than me I think he picks on me
the most and I and I lose the most
because I think the other people and you
know when you have a bunch of newspaper
people yeah newspaper people are the
biggest babies out of everybody we
criticize the most but when we get
criticized we're the biggest baby so
everyone a lot of the newspaper X
newspaper people they're all worried
about winning so then they're always
thinking there's a conspiracy Tony likes
Frank cuz he's in the studio so you got
that whole dynamic work who would be the
highest-paid guy on around the horn if
we had a salary cap there you mean an
open draft open draft first pick who's
bomani and Pablo are off it because they
have their own show yeah so they gotta
find you okay yeah so they they would
have been free agents moving to another
chef the number one give me some names
here then well what he paid well yeah
he's been around the longest he's been
around the horn yeah we should put him
on the veteran minimum though right at
this stage he you know cuz usually guys
on the veteran minimum they could still
do the job but they still you know
they're not as I don't want to say this
word he's been around longer yeah we
know that he
wants to stay so we could probably he's
like Carmelo Anthony well you shoot him
on the veteran minimum you should have
like an assisted-living around the hole
I think I think then that's what we need
to do yeah with what Tony's got all the
energy he's the one that keeps everybody
up Tony would make the most as the hosts
okay thing all right but as far as who's
on there Alina Kimes is yeah you know
emerging Jacquie McMullen is veteran me
and reliable I would say Mena Kimes
right now yeah she would be the free
agent that everyone would want and she
would get the max deal no she's smart
you know she's young she's got the whole
package worth II went to Yale so she's
had a tough life as you can does she
remind you that she went to you no she's
not like that at all cuz McLovin went to
Dartmouth and he loves to remind you
that it's not really you couldn't get
into Northwestern that's what my I
definitely could engage my Dartmouth
I've never been up there heard it's
beautiful
yeah it's gorgeous Pablo will remind you
all the he'll always slip in Harvard
yeah Lena does not slip in the Yale
comment did you know Pablo knew Jeremy
Lin you know he did think about it they
did back to back covers of Jeremy Lin
and then the next week was spring
training and the headline was Marlon
sanity they melt that one three times
back to back Jeremy Lin third time
Marlon sanity but if you look back on
that with Jeremy Lin the the
competitiveness with Carmelo and Jeremy
Lin it felt like it was tangible yeah
and all of a sudden this is Melos team
and Jeremy Lin became the darling yeah
how much friction and did that lead to
Melo asking management to get rid of
Jeremy Lin well I don't think Carmelo
had much to do with them getting rid of
him I don't think the owner was too
crazy about I think a lot of that had to
do with Jeremy didn't play in the series
against Miami remember the whole team
kind of fell apart he had had the
meniscus surgery but getting back to
your point it's the Patrick Swayze line
from dirty dancing nobody puts Baby in
the corner
nobody puts Melo in the corner and that
a lot of times they were running high
pick-and-roll and there was Carmelo
standing in the corner he don't want
that he didn't want anymore but
that was an exciting time you wonder how
long it could when they went down to
Miami if you remember right before the
all-star game it was almost like
Carmelo's buddies Dwyane Wade and LeBron
wanted to prove a point because they
were trapping Jeremy before it can get
the bowl over midcourt they wanted to
prove a point that game well it's sort
of like with Pippen and Jordan when they
faced Toni Kukoc in the Olympics exactly
you know what when Melo came in here how
many years ago was that Paulie went
three years ago maybe he was delightful
yeah and I'd be worried of eleven he
came in you turned my Carmela know tell
him his two-year yeah came into the
studio he was a great guy
and I said you you should do more yeah
because I don't know if people I mean
he's not my favorite player but I did
like him as a person
what is his legacy gonna be great score
absolutely won a lot of gold medals I
think the fact that he's only gotten out
of the first round twice will hurt him
you know you and I think one of the
things that you know that you just
mentioned Carmelo was a great guy he was
one of the best guys to deal with never
got angry at something you had written
would talk to anybody would never be a
jerk to a reporter who would just float
in for one day never and in a in a cod
kind of way I think that almost hurt him
because he was too nice and he didn't
kind of bring that anger and intensity
out onto the court he was he loved being
in the NBA he loved playing let's haul
line and let's hang out we'll all be
buddies me you LeBron Dwyane Wade and I
kind of think that that hurt him I don't
he was great and he wanted to get better
but I don't think he had that drive the
way Kobe has that Drive LeBron has it I
think that's kind of what separates you
know same thing with Michael Jordan's
what separates you know the really
really good players from those all-time
kind of players when's the last time you
had somebody approach you confront you
with something you wrote it's probably
it's probably been a while because it's
I don't think it's like that anymore I
think because of Twitter and things like
that I think you know players they get
upset about stuff like that but now what
they'll do is they'll tell someone maybe
it's a PR person or somebody in that
area and then they'll tell you that
they're upset somebody in the
organization but Stephon Marbury once
called me up was upset about that I had
written you know he and Kurt Thomas got
into a fight in the locker
and then the Knicks tried to trade him
to Cleveland so I wrote that they tried
to settle the feud in the locker room my
trading card Thomas he called me up the
next day I didn't even know that he had
my phone number and just started yelling
at me told me I better watch my back and
all this other nonsense so what I told
Kurt Thomas he thought it was pretty
funny
did Phil Jackson have an issue with you
anything you wrote yeah he was he was
really upset he had told me at one point
he reached out to me right after the his
introductory press conference and he
said hey at some point we'll sit down so
I like let it go I said he had no
problem and then maybe a year later I'd
sent him an email and he said we can do
that once your tweets and your stories
improve oh boy and I said actually I
said I say this to everybody you know we
don't it's the results that affect the
coverage it's not the other way around
the coverage does not impact the results
we're only writing about what's happened
what's happened in with the New York
Knicks the last 17 years they have the
worst record in the NBA how do you want
to cover that and the same thing happens
this year the fans have already started
with this has been great this hirings
been great this draft pick every year
the knick fans think that they've won
the summer which is fine to think that
way but we could only base it on history
what does history tell us they're pretty
pretty loyal patients our lives right I
think almost too long yeah I think in
New York I think the Mets have the best
fans because the Met fans has a standard
where they say if you put a good product
on the field we'll go to the games
the Knicks still sell out every game now
so in that way yeah they have loyal fans
but there's a lot of tourists around
things like that who go to the game the
Met fan and the jet fan is if you don't
give us a good product we're not showing
up Frank I sold up from the New York
Daily News he'd gladly give up that job
in Sirius XM NB a radio and keep around
the horn joining us here are the Knicks
in play for LeBron at all I don't know
would you be shocked at anything LeBron
did at this I would be shocked if if the
Knicks would be in play only well what
about because of David fizzed a although
that's his guy well I I can love I can
love you as a coach that doesn't mean I
have to play I can have a good
relationship you know you got a look at
ownership I got a look at his porzingis
gonna be healthy yep exactly you know is
is Knox a player I mean I I don't know
what you have on that team now I did
I did think hornacek did a pretty good
job with that team I thought that they
passed the ball if they played hard they
just they you know there wasn't a good
team I think if he signs a one-year
contract or I should say opps in in
Cleveland then he's a free agent next
year then the next would have a chance
because now you think porzingis you'll
probably get another lottery pick now
you can and they have money next summer
I think the right now the Lakers are the
team even though everything's being
floated out Cleveland he's gonna stay
and cleave and I think the Lakers are
worried about the whole tampering thing
they got in trouble for it last year
there were stories out that the Lakers
told their um you know employees be very
careful do you think it's already done
deal I he must know already what he's
gonna do I think it's me to Cleveland or
the Lakers I don't know which one but is
why if they had the last two years
they've looked at schools out there so
that has to be it has to be the Lakers
or Cleveland yeah I'm thinking i-i've
been saying all along I think it's
Cleveland I think he stays one more year
just to see sort of how LA plays out you
know if you've mentioned the Knicks is
there another debt you know how's Philly
play out - yeah Tony hope he stays in
Cleveland he's from there yeah and at
this point okay what's his record in the
finals three and three six three and six
right at nine times no all right so
Michael Jordan was six ago in the finals
but those years that he didn't make it
to the finals those count also yeah like
he's getting to the finals every year
that was my argument yeah but then the
people sell out some watered down East
that he's going through to get there
Jordan the team's he faced he's got an
order down team that he's taking yeah
but he helped watered down that team to
do that but do you get I refuse to get
into the argument about LeBron and
Michael because until it's done I just
don't know if you can yeah I don't think
it's fair to either one of them because
they're different their styles are
different LeBron doesn't play like Mike
now he's a different teammate I mean
people don't talk about LeBron is
actually a good teammate yeah Michael
wasn't a great teammate now he you had
to keep up with him and he would take
you to the promised land so the
difference was Michael Jordan wanted
every North Carolina player on him right
so he wanted Walter Davis also Davis on
the team yeah and this you know this guy
that guy and they said no no we're gonna
do it
LeBron I think has a little bit more say
and then things happen and then they say
now LeBron didn't know the Kyrie was
gonna get traded you really believe that
you really think that they're gonna
trade Kyrie Irving without LeBron
knowing about it
no come on and if it worked out I think
he would have said well you know who
thought it was time to make a trade also
here's the thing that we always laugh at
everybody's got sources but not
everybody has sources Frank all you have
to do nowadays is say I got a source I'm
hearing yeah and like we're so loose now
and journalism is not alive and well and
kicking in sports yeah how concerned are
you of where we are what it is and what
it means to the fans who are consuming
this I thought a fascinating story was
the story in the ringer right the Bryan
Colangelo thing I don't think that story
would have gotten in a newspaper because
it was a lot of you know conjecture and
trying to connect the dots I get a Bryan
Colangelo admitted to having a burner
account which by the way I think every
general manager has just to kind of keep
tabs on what you know people around the
league also media people or saying no
but that did go to like another level
with oh then it got connected to his
wife somehow and my thing was alright so
now we're gonna kill but let's say it
was his wife for argument's sake who's
tweeting out - how many people followed
that account 50 she could reach more
people opening the window here and
yelling out yeah go ask jahlil okafor
about failing his physical yet we've
already read a story from the Sixers
since Bryan Colangelo that people in the
organization did not want them to draft
Markel fault how is that story not more
damaging than that tweet about your
little Okafor Markoff votes is still on
the team so don't you feel bad for more
Cup votes how does he feel well there
are people in here don't want me and
clearly the Sixers aren't that concerned
with leaks because that got out well
somebody had to tip off somebody at the
ringer that that there were these burner
accounts because if we didn't even know
that they existed and how many followers
did she have yeah so something we still
don't know who tipped off the ringer you
know to bring this story light and don't
you think this year there's been a lot
of stuff floated out there about Kawhi
Leonard a lot of it being sourced how
come the sixth the Spurs aren't being
investigated about the koi Leonard stuff
the big thing was how well they leaked
that information about your little cup
or failing a physical you can fail a
physical for anything
Cuttino Mobley had a potentially fatal
heart condition when he got traded to
the Knicks but he had always signed a
waiver so you can bail him on the
physical blow up the trade but they
passed the physical
so jahlil okafor failing a physical is
not breaking any HIPPA laws or anything
like that it seemed like that story got
a little out of control but back to your
point about sourcing you know yeah that
was somebody who leaked it to them
obviously gave them pretty good
information because Bryan Colangelo
certainly did have that account but all
you have to say I'm hearing yeah
sources close to me and nobody can
follow up it's not like we're gonna if
you don't tell me your source and you're
writing for the New York Times are here
to put you in prison yeah you know it's
we hey I'm a hearing yeah and it just
feels it it's a little late I would say
this too let's say in the case of LeBron
you know that rich Paul his agent talks
to people he knows and there's enough
people around LeBron that tell enough
people who you know they want to be
friendly with certain reporter so
they're gonna tell them stuff so I'd
still think a lot of stuff that gets
source it's pretty reliable the players
are always gonna deny it that's the way
that they do it would levar ball pause
you know have you pause if you're LeBron
James that going into the Laker
absolutely absolutely
I think Lonzo ball was on the team if
LeBron I don't think so I think they're
gonna try to get rid of him
even though he first of all he played
him 52 games right he shoots what 30%
from the field and on Three's and my
team he's under 50 from the line I know
right now I think I think it's like 46
in the whole situation with the dad and
at first it was funny we had him on our
show you laugh but then as things went
on they told them please you know take
it just tone it down a little bit then
he came out and killed Luke Walton then
he's pulling his kids out of school
they're playing over Lithuania then he
says our kids are gonna play together
and I get it everyone wanted to give him
father of the year because he cares
about his kids that's how usually every
father is I think you we use better
judgment do you think it's good judgment
that he pulled this kid out of UCLA and
now the kid didn't get drafted where
would you rather be as an 18 19 year old
playing a little way Nia making I don't
even know what he was making or hanging
on the UCLA campus playing basketball we
don't know how long he would have had to
sit out at UCLA but I think that he
needed a year of structured basketball
because high school if you saw him play
in high school he would be at the other
end of the floor
he wasn't even playing defense and he
shooting is many times as he wanted and
then you go to Lithuania there's no
structure there as well and I think you
know he's the third best player in the
family yeah he needed struction that was
the word coming out of high school that
he's not really the NBA guy so wooden
multiple years of college basketball he
need I think is an eighteen year old
it's a pretty fun time to live your life
be in college at a place like UCLA
playing in the pac-10 your brother's
playing right down the road at Staples
Center you're in a pretty good situation
I think he went kicking and screaming to
Lithuania what I think against Lithuania
I don't want to go there as an 18 year
old when I could be at UCLA but then you
have Lee Angelo who's now not gonna be
able to go to college yeah Camela the
young ones lamella yeah so now he's
another one that could use straw I
watched him play
I watched high school games that they
played not clips I watched high school
games they need structure I know
because their game is really
undisciplined even now they're getting
it's like AAU basketball you get into
bad habits there and that's part of the
problem with these younger kids going
into the NBA they don't have structure
and and don't you think the father put a
target on the kid because he did so much
talking he's gonna be Rookie of the Year
he's gonna lead them to the championship
this and that and where he really lost
me was all the bravado my son's gonna
come out he's gonna be the number one
pick that's great the minute they lost
in the NCAA tournament he started
blaming his teammate I know the father
you don't you don't do that
why are you blaming like somebody else's
you know eighteen ninety but do you
think there's a sign-and-trade with
Cleveland to the Lakers with LeBron he
might he might do something like that
because there nobody wants to help them
out what does it have to help them out
no but everybody wants money yeah like a
little I don't think LeBron is gonna go
what the Lakers could sign him out right
though or he can opt into his contract
and do what Chris Paul did last year
with the Clippers and you sin you opt in
you're getting you a thirty million then
you're getting traded so technically a
sign-and-trade yes yeah what would you
have to give up to get LeBron you want
to feel the Lakers young players and
picks but but they don't have picks
I know so you're gonna get Lonzo and
in Ingram would you do that I wouldn't
do Lonzo ball I'll do Brittany well
Cleveland's got Collin Sexton you know
exactly so that's another thing so if
you could well qu I'm not gonna get
Kuzma and Ingram for LeBron are you I
want that's where we're gonna start and
then your partner gonna have to take
back a bad contract to make it all fit
somehow Timothy Mozgov will be in the
deal Nick yo yeah they're all okay if
you went back and you changed one move
you know draft pick move with it for the
Knicks a higher you can change one wait
long would you you know what they should
have done Donnie Walsh Mike D'Antoni
were in love with Steph Curry
they knew that they should have done
anything they could to trade up in front
of the Golden State Warriors they should
have trusted their instincts on that one
you think that's the one move a law they
love Steph Curry Mike did they try to
trade up maybe they did but come on you
could have knowing what you know now you
should have done anything you could to
get him that's like a different level
are you one around the horn today yes I
am so check your local listings Dan I
mean if you could give a [ __ ]
you should guest host guest host on what
I guest host on a realm of horn if tony
reality ask yeah and I would consider it
all right yeah no it's not that easy
it's not like hosting SportsCenter
that's like a hit okay that's like an a
dime-a-dozen you have to you know mute
button give points this is real work I
mean it's it's a tough 22 minutes that
you have to deal with there I mean it's
you should see the pretty crazy there
god 22 minutes it's not like sitting in
a palace like you have exhausted to do
22 minutes of taped TV what remember one
thing and I brought up before high
maintenance newspaper people oh I know
that I guess babies out of everyone see
I don't know if I would give you guys
any points no you don't have to the
score might be like seven to five here's
the thing about the show they accused me
all the time of being a homer which I'm
not papilla clap Lasky's all he's the
biggest Homer it's unbeliev yeah yes yes
he's mr. Dodge or mr. Laker
I mean Boston people I mean Jackie's
pretty uh could you take everybody on
around the horn and I buy it like in the
Octagon let me see like plasticy looks
like he's a wrestler I bet he was
arrested in high school Cyrus Payton was
a heptathlon
Sara Spain is probably the best I'm down
there yeah I like seriously I walked on
I spent one year Marilyn walk on the
soccer team I just kept walking see you
later
keep walking go away it was a walk and
when I was on the team they weren't good
now they're like a national tower you
know so Taylor Twellman broke all my
record you watch it primarily gonna be
saying the Premier League Premier League
yeah you watch jackal Oh unbelievable
host yes he's great they do great I've
actually been to that the old shampoo
factory up there to watch them do the
show that's how much I like Obie NBC's
yes beautiful the shampoo factory yeah
that's what he used to be right I don't
know yeah yeah I know I know that you
work for NBC you never know thank you
Frank he's Frank I saw it and he says
LeBron is going to the Lakers you know
hopefully Cleveland you got sources yes
are you hearing hearing word on the
street
Frank went around the horn tonight and
if he wins a nice shout-out to the Dan
Patrick yes I think would be an order
that day nice Frank yes and check with
reality if he wants me to host around
the horn I don't want to have you to
dishonor your people at NBC my people
his people yeah I don't have people so I
think I think he'd have to talk to his
people at ESPN that would be the key
that'd be a big I'd be a big coup it'd
be a big ratings it'd be a today I bet
not get in trouble for talking about
people on around the horn I won't get in
trouble
edit that out okay yeah we will for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]